quelques maisons individuelles des
logements sociaux une école un collège
et même une piscine la rue raymond
vergès de la possession est à la fois un
lieu de vie et une voie de passage mais
l'évolution récente de ce quartier
at-elle effacé raymond vergès des
mémoires
à mon avis non peut-être le pape
allemand de piaf veut
pas lâcher quoi sur manhattan écrivain
professeur il était médecin des pauvres
vergès et c'est connu dans le milieu
paul de la politique était meilleure ce
temps là cette année
louis adolph raymond vergès est né à
saint denis en 1882 sur les traces de
son père pharmacien il entreprend des
études de médecine et en parallèle fait
math sup diplôme en poche il se lance
dans l'agronomie
curieux mais pauvre il part en chine
pour payer ses cours de médecine sur
place il est ingénieur sur le chantier
du chemin de fer de mandchourie
de retour en france le jeune médecin
doit cesser d'exercer pour cause de
première guerre mondiale
la guerre finie il retourne en chine il
sera même consul de france au siam avant
de revenir définitivement dans son île
natale en 1931
médecins à hell bourg à saint-andré puis
nommé directeur du service de santé il
s'engage dans la politique pour défendre
les opprimés
avec le crac le comité républicain
d'action démocratique et sociale il pose
les fondements de ce qui deviendra le
parti communiste réunionnais
la cgt témoignage c'est en affichant ses
convictions de gauche progressiste qu'il
remporte haut la main les élections
municipales de 1945 dans trois communes
entre saint-andré saint paul et saint
denis il choisira la dernière
peu après il est désigné avec léon de
lépervanche pour représenter la réunion
à l'assemblée nationale
côte à côte ils oeuvrent à la
départementalisation de la réunion et à
l'égalité sociale
raymond vergès mort le 2 juillet 1957